So it's really useful to not defend
yourself to vociferously,
which is weird because you'd think,
well,
you have the right to defend yourself,
like no all,
no holds barred.
It's like,
no,
it actually doesn't work that way.
You have to defend yourself with minimal
necessary force.
And I think I managed that in the
channel for interview for thank God,
but I mean believe me,
people have been talking to me about
that nonstop for 15 months and I'm
listening
and it wouldn't work as well if he
hadn't done that right.
If you just show laughter,
right?
The idea,
if he'd just gotten right at her and
said,
what you are saying is so stupid for
these five reasons,
it would,
it would have been bad.
I think that's actually the fact that
you sat there and he just said,
no,
you're asking good questions and you
know,
the fact that you're asking good
questions demonstrates the validity of
your entire viewpoint that that was much
more effective.
Right.
Well,
and that's one of the things I've been
meditating on for the last years.
There's a line in the new testament
says,
resist not evil.
Thank you.
Okay.
What the hell are you supposed to do?
It's like because it's really a
difficult thing to figure out.
Do you really mean that you don't resist
evil?
Well,
there's a couple of problems is if you
punch back then you have a fight.
Well,
but you can't just not defend yourself
like weekly.
You can't be weak and not defend
yourself,
but you can be strong and defend
yourself minimally.
And that's a real art.
Like that's,
that's the essence of sophistication.
I would say.
Like I'm not,
you know,
I come from kind of a rough place.
I'm coming from northern Alberta.
I come from the frontier,
you know,
my town was scraped out of the bloody
prairie 50 years before people moved
before,
before I lived there.
And so,
uh,
it's,
it's been an,
it's been a continual challenge to just
my sophistication to the level of
challenge and I've,
I'm trying to do that.
Do you think that.
I don't always manage it.
Yeah.
So to that point,
do you think that we sometimes actually
at a deep level use identity politics
against ourselves in,
in this regard?
So you're sitting across from Kathy,
she's female.
Yeah.
At some level.
Do you think you may be moderated it
because of that?
Because had it been a male,
you know,
and you talk about this often,
that we have to act differently towards
males and females and there's a
physical,
there's a physical reasons for that and
biological reasons for that,
but that had she been a male,
say,
say the same exact age from you,
from Alberta and all of that,
that perhaps your response might have
been a little more forceful even though
you're.
We're all agreeing your response was
done correctly and evenhandedly.
Yeah.
Well I.
It's hard to say,
but probably yes.
That's interesting because you did like,
I can't,
I don't think that you can say that you
fight with a woman the same way that you
fight with a man.
That doesn't mean you can't fight with a
woman.
Doesn't mean you shouldn't,
but I don't think the rules are the
same.
Now,
why are the rules different?
Well,
some of the rules are,
there's a physical limit.
It's much more stringent,
right?
I mean,
there's a level of hinting out physical
threat that you can bring to bear in a
conversation between men that you cannot
bring to bear in a conversation with a
woman.
So,
and the mechanics of that are very,
very subtle and difficult and it's
especially challenging in an
intellectual discussion because an
intellectual discussion is a kind of war
and it isn't obvious how men and women
should go to war with one another.
We don't know.
We don't know how to sort that out.
Um,
my sense has been on the panels that
I've done is that I definitely have to
pull my punches.
If I'm on a panel with women,
that doesn't mean that I don't.
It doesn't mean that it's any less
challenging intellectually,
but the strategy and the attitude has to
be different.
It's much more likely that you'll be
seen as a bully if you bring the same
force to bear on a female opponent as
you would on a male opponent.